while in their social Superior to men oh
he just said women of superior to men in
one aspect it's never sex is when a guy
mentions something about one that's
positive hey guys and welcome back to
the lay Heil Pancho today I'm going to
be reacting to Myron's grilling or his
date so I'm really curious to see how
this goes before I get into this guys
don't forget to hit the like button and
also if you enjoy this kind of content
then don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button so you can see more of these kind
of videos hey what's up how are you
hello
you're gonna give me a hug or what wait
this is so I love it Myron has no filter
absolutely she should stand up and give
him a hug if this is the first instant
of female entitlement just so rude men
are expected to stand up a woman could
just sit on her ass Myron is clearly
like not gonna hold back I can just tell
from that initial opening um experience
thank you I try he made me hug him yeah
I don't know why I've done that
so how are you chilling chilling well
yeah yeah cool how about yourself I'm
good thank you good it's a bit hot here
though summer hands yeah it is it is
warm I will say that it's definitely
warm this is Walgreens oh I like that
attractive but typical girl
yeah a typical girl because she was
already on the defense and wouldn't
stand up
uh I'm a professional misogynist no I'm
just kidding
Love by some hated by many just on the
internet yeah on the internet yeah we're
both on the Internet it's a strange life
yeah I've seen some videos you're not a
fan of me are you ah you know
I'm not a fan of many things yeah you
just happen to be in there maybe a
little bit why is that we disagree on
some things I think we might get on
though that's why I'm like into
interested off to a great start he hates
me I think it's very important to be
able to articulate your views and if you
don't agree with someone it doesn't mean
you have to hate them but you know I
think being too agreeable is not very
especially as a man because typically if
a guy is too agreeable you can't trust
them absolutely 100 correct this is why
I do not like male feminists can't trust
them some of the greatest male feminists
like Justin Trudeau these are bad people
so already Myron's spot on
yep so well at least the man actually
admits all men are trying to get laid oh
yeah 100 it's absolutely pointless to
have a female friend no no it's not
pointless to have a female friend very
important so you don't have any female
friends absolutely not it's a waste of
time how is it a waste of time because
women don't offer much utility to you as
a guy what makes you think that
well I mean if you get in some kind of
fight she can't do nothing what you're
going to do oh my God
if anything she's a liability that's
what I'm trying to say with fire like
I'd fight a woman for you if you're my
man I don't want myself to be involved
in any type of what do you want to fight
firstly like I swear some women don't
even know how to be attractive to men
men don't want women that fight why do
you want to fight that's that's not her
job so I look at it like if I'm with a
girl and I'm supposed to protect her and
provide for her Etc I want that to be my
woman I'm not going to give that type of
energy to like a friend that's stupid
why am I gonna put my life on the line
for a girl that doesn't even suck my
dick wait but is that too much there I
think you should just be able to have a
friendship with women though well well
firstly it's not always like men versus
women so I kind of feel like having
female friends will give you that
balance to understand like there's
actually nice normal women out there
that aren't just trying to sleep with
you like for your money or everything
like that we bring a lot of value
I've interviewed almost 1600 women now
at this point and I would say without a
shadow without women are absolutely
terrible at being understanding what it
takes to be attractive to women as a man
I literally just said that so their
advice typically is not good at all yeah
one thousand six hundred women
poor women men carry like a lot of like
hurt and they push it on women okay in
what way yeah I think it's because like
for example this Intel culture of which
like respectfully like your podcast
really brings to life you're just
projecting onto women unnecessarily
because I think fresh and fit and
everything that this red pill Community
are doing are actually really important
because it provides women with the
reality on a silver platter right there
in front of them which I think is really
important so they don't end up hitting
30 single forever alone no kids all
types of communities are going to
attract the worst of the worst but I
still stand by the fact that women can
learn so much from this red pilled space
because there's a lot of good women like
I myself would say I'm a good woman I
don't do anything wrong I'm very loyal
I'm a kind woman and a lot of men will
make the assumptions because of podcasts
like yours and people and men like you
to then push that one to me that I'm
this kind of woman I'm a gold digger and
I'm in this and that and I'm not well
the reality is would it be fair to say
that most men I mean you said there's a
whole insult culture Etc would it be
fair to say that most guys are losers
and don't don't really measure up I
personally don't think that but
um I personally don't like genuinely I
don't she's lying okay correct I'll keep
it real since you don't want to most
guys I'll be honest are fat losers and
don't have leadership qualities and
there's a whole bunch of reasons for
that and most women quite frankly are
terrible they're [ __ ] fat rude crass
whatever it may be and most of them
don't qualify for relationship and most
guys don't qualify to be the leader of
set relationships yeah I think it goes
on both parts okay the men are weak and
the women there's a bunch of issues
there and they're disgusting so when we
basically highlight on our podcast is
you need to be the best version of
yourself and I think the thing is is
that guys are yearning for this because
we've been lying to men for the better
part of five to six decades about what
being masculine and strong actually is
we've been demonizing it when in reality
guys need to become stronger because no
woman wants a weak man Even though girls
say dumb [ __ ] like go well you know I
want you to be emotionally intelligent
and get in tune with your feelings or
whatever it's all a lie
no there's a but I personally would like
a man that's emotionally available yeah
and emotionally intelligent but it's not
me saying like I want you crying all the
time so I mean it's true though like so
I understand what you're saying but at
the same time you have to give some room
for men because like men's mental health
is a serious like issue we tell guys not
to be vulnerable in front of your girl
you know you you go ahead you're going
to be vulnerable You're Going to shed a
tear whatever you do that around other
men that understand you know the male
experience women don't understand the
male experience at all and it goes to
show like when I said earlier when you
put the girl in a male perspective I
want you to pick up this girl they
always fall flat on their face because
women are in a privileged position where
they don't have to necessarily
understand what it takes to attract the
man because men come to them for me as a
partner I would want to be able to give
my man a safe space to be able to be
vulnerable and it's like but not
completely like oh my God cry all the
time but just so he knows like it's like
things are okay
you know like it's supposed to be a
partnership no it's not a partnership
that's another common lion modern day
dating it's not a problem I want a
partnership though no you don't you're
lying do you want a man that's taller
than you idealistically speaking I think
you're probably because I like to wear
Hills I like to be safe fantastic do you
want to gather stronger than you yes
yeah do you want a guy that makes more
money than you yes I'm not faster that
money she's lying yeah I wanted to make
at least your equivalent if not
preferably better remember this is your
ideal guy yeah yeah okay do you want a
guy that's
more confident than yourself
yeah more experience than yourself yeah
yeah okay you basically describe the
superior so you expect this guy to come
in and have a partnership with you
whatever he might Myron is so good to
add value in other ways because it's not
always about being physically on the
same on par with that person just for
certain requirements like you can't burf
a baby
so we complement each other yeah in
other ways and so we're still equal in
that sense men and women are not equal
at all
totally agree men and women are not
equal everyone gets so emotional about
this I don't even want them to be equal
as a woman you want a man that's better
than you in every way more successful
smarter more intelligent more
charismatic we're not equal I'm looking
for somebody better that's another
fallacy that we have in modern day
dating culture which leads so many women
Australia we're not the same there's
certain things that men can do that
women can can't do and vice versa and
we're different and we're designed to
complement each other and I don't
believe in Partnerships I think men come
in and Lead women follow yes we need a
dictatorship and a patriarchy we need to
bring back the patriarchy you know
um and I find it funny because women
typically want a man and here's the
thing what you just described is what
every girl wants yeah but they think
that they're going to go into religion
with a guy that's better than them every
single metric and it's going to be an
equal partnership for 50 50. it doesn't
work that way there's always a leader
there's always a decider and for it to
work the man's got to be in leadership
role never the woman yes please we can't
lead anything it creates too much
pressure on you as a man then who cares
this like matching man do you not think
that's going to cause a lot of strain on
a relationship pressure creates diamonds
because here's the thing women are just
a cherry on top like you you should have
already built a cake by the time she
comes into the picture yeah you know you
should have already conquered a
boardroom or conquered some kind of
physical labor yeah Sports at some point
in your life endured some kind of stress
like men need to go through pain men
must become women are men must become
being a loser is unacceptable if you're
broke fat or you don't got yourself
together that's your problem yeah but
then yes
you'd say oh they only come for like the
glory of it like not the graph so I'd
rather be with someone that I'm building
with I've never I've never said that
women build I actually say the contrary
I say women don't build they move in
yeah but and I acknowledge that
interesting reality 100 I tell guys they
need to build the castle so that she can
come in and yeah you know put some
things up here and there in your Castle
beautiful you got to build the structure
women are going to build it with you
those days are done women some women do
though like a lot of women
no a few the ones I know I would say a
minority a majority want a guy that
comes pre-assembled correct correct
about
she's lying I don't know why women are
like this they talk about emotional
intelligence but they're not being
emotionally honest or intellectually
honest or even self-aware Myron is 100
spot on I agree with everything Myron's
saying right now I've already not the
minority if I'm advising men how to you
know operate in a daily Marketplace I
can't tell them look out for this 10
that wants to build with you no the
reality is Muslim and want you to come
pre-assembled and to be honest the most
attractive and youngest women that have
the most options they definitely want
you to come pre-assembled women want
winners they sit at the finish line and
pick the winners where did you grow up I
grew up in New Britain Connecticut
two hours north of New York City so what
was your upbringing like
great parents were together the whole
time stable I had a sister brother had
um so I mean they're still alive now
yeah
like they're gone yeah
um yeah I mean I grew up went to high
school played basketball in high school
played video games I still have my
chocolate friends to this day I would
say I grew up like in a pretty good
situation we didn't grow up with money
right we grew up fairly you know poor
little you know lower middle class my
parents struggled especially in the
beginning yeah I mean I wouldn't trade
it for the world I think it's important
for young men to grow up like struggling
I think it's you you build character you
have to do it yeah when you're born rich
as a man it's so bad you don't build any
character you don't build any strength
you're not faced with problems that you
then learn and evolve from I think
Challenge and struggle is so important
for a man it builds him into the best
man possible uh I would raise my son to
not be a victim you know I'm at a point
now where a very successful financially
but my son would not see any of this
money yeah I would make him get enough
the mud because like we discussed before
trust fund babies typically don't know
what to do in life and how to you know
they don't understand and appreciate the
value of a dollar and I thank my dad for
instilling in that mean that in me early
I mean my first job was at McDonald's
and I got fired and I quickly learned
that I didn't want to be in the service
industry but it made me appreciate
people in the service industry so how do
you find dating then with the way that
you are I mean when you understand uh
the code it's you know Plug and Play
yeah but you have an easy time teaching
deal with the girl size her up figure
out what kind of trick she is and then
bam you know you already know kind of
how to how to move so like what's the
code depends on the girl okay you got to
be able to adapt based on the woman that
you're sitting across the table from
yeah I have the female codes in my
sleeves I know pretty much what they all
are
you want me to be honest yeah of course
okay I want the code now and then I'll
ask the code again by the end of it yeah
I would say uh recreational use only no
offense so what's like the old how many
codes is there well it depends on the
girl you know if you deal with a girl
that's younger that's in her prime years
well you got to understand that she's
more you know inclined to look for fun
if you're dealing with a girl that is in
her mid-20s a lot of times and she might
be pursuing you know it depends on the
girl but she might be pursuing some type
of stability or some security and you
got to play at that angle or if you deal
with a girl that's a little bit older
late 20s 30s or not nine out of ten
times she's going to want some type of
security if she hasn't gotten there
already code it's not even that deep
like either you like them or not you
don't need to put them in categories so
what kind of woman do you want sorry me
I mean I could deal with whatever my
thing is I need her come into my life
and be an asset and not a liability
correct most girls are liabilities
correct do you think I think the right
woman though could like really just
compliment you and make you like that's
what he just said that's what he just
said Ask how to train him no you haven't
in order to train someone you need them
to listen I'm telling you no woman is
listening to you yes she is I'm sitting
here listening saying everything Myron
is saying is spot on as a man yeah you
need a woman that's an asset whether
she's going to you know make your life
more peaceful whether she's going to
create a clean home for you and so that
you can focus on your mission and
provide for the both of them I'm sitting
here listening and I'm like yeah you'll
spot on my own like most girls come into
your life like and if you don't know
what you're doing she's going to come in
as a liability correct no you don't
train them though yes you do it's like
training a dog you wouldn't do that oh
here we go no but it's true though it's
not training it's not something like
once again it's just seeing this person
as you're equal okay but sure you want
to have some respect it's not training
so I look at it like if I'm gonna have a
girlfriend and she's going to be my girl
and she's going to have my title well
she's got to be trained to rise up to a
certain level because I'm going to make
her into an asset buy me a bag do this
blah blah blah Take Me Out trips
whatever when they haven't earned it so
you gotta de-train those bad behaviors
out of that girl and make her an asset
into your life versus a liability mostly
this is something that I actually want
to ask Myron can you be bothered to
train a woman wouldn't you rather pick a
woman who is already aware of all these
things is ready just to fall into your
frame fall into your lifestyle or would
you rather spend time training a woman I
don't know I'm just interested I just
don't understand her value they bring
her onto their life they give her
everything she hasn't earned it she
doesn't respect them she's walking all
over him she started to dictate the
relationship you're not getting sex
tonight blah blah blah
so rude no he's not this is your
experience so I can't argue that but I
mean this is this is this is biology
women are hardwired to extract resources
for men it's been that way since the
beginning of time yeah biology rules
everything guys they could sit there and
say oh but I'm doing this and my truth
blah blah blah biology rules you there's
one truth there's no such thing as my
truth female typical blah blah blah
trash correct
no but I kind of feel like from my
experience if I've gone into if I'm
going into someone's life I would want
to add value so I wouldn't really take
things and I kind of feel when you what
did you just say two seconds ago in my
experience you might come in and I add
it value yeah that's you majority women
come in meet the guy okay but also she
is adding value all women want to add
value that's being the the set versus
not
value that you add peace helping him
doesn't mean like being his business
partner no it means making his life as
easy as possible okay what can I get
from this guy okay this guy's a Sim I'll
just take him out on dinner dates you
could pay I'm never gonna smash him
another guy this guy's hot you know I
can smash him I can hang out with him
this guy he has some utility he's a
plumber okay you do my Plumbing bro it's
hard BJ wants girls put guys in roles
it's your job as the man to make sure to
you're the top guy and you got the main
role where you're not investing too much
and she's investing more in you girls
own respect men that they invest in the
girl always has to like the guy more
than she likes him yeah I think he works
better rounds when the guy likes to grow
more yeah
that doesn't make sense
because women want a man is better than
them yeah so how do I look if I'm better
than you and I'm sitting here Chasing
After You doesn't make sense women only
respect men that they chase it doesn't
work the other way around once again
with this like new wave of women we
don't want to keep fighting for a man if
he's going to treat you like an option
women want the best of the best of the
best right so if he's so available to
you and you know puts you on this
pedestal and simps for you then you know
you're going to be wondering like what's
going on I thought this guy's the best
of the best I'm all for monogamy but you
do have to find a good balance you don't
really want a man that's simping for you
so here's the thing we can say that
women are changing whatever but we're
all slaves are biology women are 100
okay with sharing men it's been that way
since beginning of time it's I would say
it's even more apparent now with
Instagram dating apps Etc a minority of
men are getting a majority of the women
yep and women are okay with that I mean
walk into a nightclub walk into a
nightclub it's probably one of the most
carnal representations of human nature
all the women are sitting in one section
with a bunch of the the guys that have
the highest perceived status in that
social setting versus all the other guys
are out there in general admission
struggling women always gravitate
towards the best guys and they're
willing to share those guys there are
more high value young beautiful women
than the high value older men and so you
do have to share but at the same time
you know if if you're really the best
woman then hopefully you can make a man
be monogamous and exclusive to you I
think that is certainly possible but I
think it's the woman's responsibility to
make herself so amazing and so much
better than all the other competition
that he will be exclusive just for her
so what's your type my type fit feminine
friendly perfect submissive and
coachable and coachable to be trained
you've got to train women man I know
that sounds terrible I fully agree I've
been trained by my brother I don't think
I'd be so based and red pilled if it
wasn't for my brother so shout out to
Gideon who by the way is probably
editing this video so follow him Link in
description Instagram women don't like
it when they get criticized if I go on a
podcast and I say you know what guys
need to stop being bombs you need to get
your money on point not being fat poses
Etc they actually admire and respect
that people are in the FL in the chat
flame emojis whatever I go on rants on
the guys all the time I'm sweating going
crazy it's like I'm delivering a preach
I think she's trying to grow me but what
she doesn't know is I'm a black belt in
this I've dealt with 10 girls like her
at the same time on my podcast so yeah
women rarely get held accountable for
their poor decisions men do though men
have to live in reality women are
afforded the privilege of being
delusional so when a guy criticizes a
woman oh my God right if you don't
believe me think about it if a dude's
fat we just call him fat you're a loser
huh form is fat love your curves girl
this is so accurate I don't want to be
rude or mean or anything but I was at a
dinner with this woman who was so obese
she was telling me how she couldn't find
any swimwear for girls who are curvy I
thought it's myself oh my God like
you're refusing to live in reality
you're delusional I am curvy you are
obese and she kept referring to herself
as curvy women they just think take no
accountability and they don't live in
reality she's delusional she's rude and
obnoxious oh you know what they just
can't handle you you're strong and
independent Fierce we have all these
terms female inadequacies but we don't
have these same terms for men I think it
just a lot of it comes from like
narcissistic behavior from men women are
far more narcissistic narcissistic women
can be so I'm not I'm not disputing but
I kind of feel like with men that attain
a certain level of status and power you
it gives you the opportunity to try and
to to dominate no but no but this is men
earn narcissism men do not earn a right
to be narcissistic like just shut up
men earn confidence and arrogance women
don't women are born with their value
men must earn their value so if a man's
arrogant more than likely he's probably
accomplished something when a woman's
arrogant nine out of ten times she
hasn't accomplished anything she just
has a bunch of DMS see this is the
problem that a lot of modern day women
have they lack critical thinking skills
correct
ah
women tend to go off of their feelings
versus what's real they go off the
fields and not the reals What A girl is
supposed to do is come into a man's life
see where he's deficient okay I noticed
that you like to go to the gym at this
time I'm going to make sure that you
have a protein shake with as many grams
of protein as you need just get a pi
I'm going to make sure that's done and
I'm a deductive Problem Solver I'm able
to be observant because that's a women's
gift is being observant of social
situations that's why women are socially
Superior to men oh he just said women
are superior to men in one aspect it's
never section
so women are superior to men in a
certain way and that's okay that's not
sexist it's so funny if a woman's job is
to use that social calibration that they
have that they're Superior to men in and
be able to be like okay this guy's
deficient in this and the fish and this
Etc let me come in compliment make this
guy operate he's already operating at 95
I'm going to get him to one or two
that's a good woman that extra two three
four five percent is what helps you beat
the competition this guy is dangerous a
lot of women will give you that life
they will give you that balance they
will compliment you but they're not
going to just do it until you're serious
you know because men like to play the
field for a very long time when you're
with a guy of value you got to
understand that he has a leverage not
you correct you're applying to be his
girlfriend I wear the highway baby
because at the end of the day when you
can replace a girl that's when she
respects you that's really true and
that's a a sad reality that women have
to learn and should learn actually much
faster women are like I'm the prize you
know you prove yourself to me I'm not
going to do all these amazing things to
you unless I know you're serious about
me but unfortunately men are the prize
and yeah you're applying to be his wife
so you have to prove yourself to him
because he does in fact have all the
leverage like I said there's less high
value men than there are women it's on
the woman to prove to me that she's
worthy of a relationship that's where a
lot of girls make a mistake they'll sit
there and say I'm good I'm loyal blah
blah blah blah I want to you know see
how you do before you get promoted I'm
not going to give a girl the position of
a secretary or underboss right or second
in charge of my company unless she's
been vetted she's got to work her way up
yeah the problem is that we give women
CEO jobs when they haven't proven
themselves and they don't respect the
job who's listening to this man me so
you're here's the thing you're looking
at equality from a human perspective I'm
not saying that men are better than
women from a human perspective I'm
saying that men are leaders so therefore
we cannot be
when you're on the battlefield right and
the lieutenant or whoever the the
commanding officer is on the battlefield
they're not equal to him as you know a
regular Soldier he is the leader you're
not equal but there's a reason there's a
hierarchy to dictate order if the woman
is equal to the guy well who's going to
make the final decision nothing gets
done by a committee there always has to
be one leader in charge there's a reason
why there's a president there's a CEO
Etc both people can't be Alphas as they
say the problem is this women are
confused about what men actually want
they think CEO a boss a business owner
ambitious uh competitive woman yeah we
don't give a [ __ ] about none of that
stuff men don't care about that and I
would argue the more money a man makes
the less he cares about his woman's
ability to earn money men and women are
not the same and men and women are also
not equal and I think people
unnecessarily get so offended by that
saying that men and women on equal
doesn't mean we're saying that a man is
better than a woman or a woman is better
than a man nobody's better nobody's
higher nobody's has more intrinsic value
than the other person but in terms of we
physically equal no men tend to be
taller men tend to be stronger men tend
to be more logical women tend to be more
emotional so we're not equal but that
doesn't mean anybody is of higher value
spiritually or whatever people will just
take this whole thing way too seriously
so do you want a relationship
monogamous so how many girlfriends do
you want
I mean as many as I can I mean I
probably have four wives I think I could
do four there's nine months four wives
he's going back 500 years four wives the
way to go because if one acts stupid you
can go ahead and get another one really
yeah why well
most guys are monogamous are monogamous
out of force if I line up 100 dudes and
I said listen man you keep your
girlfriend
right while you simultaneously smash
these girls she's not gonna care he's
gonna take it every time most guys have
to kind of concede to what their girl
wants this stupid quote happy wife happy
life I think that's the dumbest quote
ever that is a good question I hate why
because a woman's job is to please the
man not the other way around
each other women are pleased by being
with the best man
in in the area that women are pleased by
you being the best version of yourself
as a man gains more status success
income Etc the woman wins she's all his
successes she benefits from that it's
not the same when a woman makes more
money orange and my status Etc and she
starts to outgrow her man she's going to
look for a better man men and women are
not the same so I bet some women we are
emotional beings like we will stay with
you no but we will stay with the man
like if a man loves us and his lawyer we
will stay really is that why women
initiate an overwhelming amount of the
breakups because they're emotional and
they're loyal no Cheyenne is single why
because she wants the best man possible
so what she's saying isn't true I'm sure
there are plenty of men that love her
with simp for her but she hasn't married
them why because what she's saying is
rubbish she wants the best man possible
not the man that's going to love her the
most the more a man seems for her the
more she's going to be repulsed by him I
agree with Myron on pretty much
99.9 of things I feel like shy and
really didn't like him I think Cheyenne
is doing the usual thing that women do
which is being not self-aware not
intellectually honest there's a reason
why she's still single it's because
she's looking for the best man and I
hope she finds it and I hope my own gets
as many wives as he deserves so guys I
hope you enjoyed the video I'm going to
be doing a lot more like this and if you
did enjoy it then don't forget to hit
the like button and also stick around
because I have a lot of podcast guests
coming we're going to be covering crypto
Bitcoin and of course more of this kind
of content so if you want to see more of
that don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button and we'll see you all next week